all right the message is to take back
life that's coming from norway's health
minister as that country begins to lift
its coveted restrictions other european
countries are also taking similar steps
to get back to normal we've talked about
england they're no longer requiring mask
or vaccine passports for public spaces
the work from home order has been lifted
there could this be a sign that the
never-ending pandemic is actually
coming to an end is it time for the u.s
to follow the lead of these other
countries let's welcome in now host of
the reuben report dave rubin his next
book don't burn this country comes out
in april and i'll keep promoting it
until april actually gets here uh but
dave great to see you and you know if if
we were going to see a thermonuclear war
with russia maybe that has something to
do with these countries in the
restrictions if we're going to go all
we're going to go down in flames let's
go ahead and lift the restrictions and
enjoy our lives of course i kid
um but in all serious you see no you see
norway other countries england
realizing it's time to get on with our
lives
you know john i hadn't put that together
that perhaps the lifting of restrictions
was directly related to world war three
but it would be nice if there's going to
be this master massive war in eastern
europe that we would have a few weeks to
go out to restaurants go out to bars
hang out with people dance halls pool
clubs whatever the young people are
doing these days
but seriously
it is time to end all of the
restrictions period individuals should
be allowed to make whatever choices they
want to make relative to if you want to
get 87 boosters if you want a triple
mask if you never want to go outside if
you want to work remotely forever you
should make whatever choice is right for
you your family you know talk to your
doctor etc but the day of these
governments these states deciding how we
all should live i think is long past
gone uh gone and john as you know you
know i moved down here to florida where
in essence covet is over that doesn't
mean that kovid doesn't exist you still
see some people wearing masks but ron
desantis has left it up to the people
that's very different from where i left
which was los angeles which as you know
mayor eric garcetti was at the rams game
on sunday without a mess he claims that
he holds his breath yes we have pictures
with people
and uh newsom was there too i mean these
people are ridiculous but the point is
you have to now be responsible for your
life the policies
have failed at virtually every level it
is time to move on i want to play
garcetti's excuse just because it is
it's so ridiculous here he is
and when people ask for a photograph i
hold my breath and i put it here and
people could see that there's a zero
percent chance of infection from that
dave i know now there's somebody is on a
mission to try and take a picture with
eric garcetti and you make sure the
picture lasts a long time like 45
seconds so
he has to hold his breath
take the picture i mean come on who's
worse in your opinion i mean because we
all we already played the awful excuse
from gavin newsom who was worse gavin
newsom or eric garcetti
john i was trying to hold my breath for
your whole diatribe there geez who's
worse i mean these people are so
profoundly inauthentic they cannot say
anything true they do not care about
their citizens he's a liar that what he
does is hold his breath when he takes
pictures and if you really believe the
pandemic was as deadly and whatever else
is there telling us you wouldn't even
accept that as a rational uh way about
way to go about your health but also the
idea that you would hold your breath so
someone comes up to you hey mr mayor can
i take a picture with you you're doing a
really great job in los angeles first
off that person can't even exist
but the person comes up and says that
well now
you've just inhaled all of their all of
their germs these people are ridiculous
gavin newsom is a chronic liar and an
authoritarian and i want nothing to do
with them and john you know i made a i
made a
statement on my show that going forward
if i gratuitously mention california i
have to put five dollars into a little
kitty and at the end of the year i'm
putting i'm going to give thousands of
dollars away to somebody to one person
to move to florida i'll just give them
thousands of bucks and since i did it on
john bachman's show i'm going to throw
in another five for this one right i
feel somewhat responsible i will chip in
five dollars because we feel that we
feel we know we feel the need to ask you
about these folks and i know you tried
to market it down john thousands of
miles away from them but uh i'll do my
best not to bring it up um because i
also went for five all right i also want
to talk about what's going on in canada
with justin trudeau and these truckers
he is locked down in isolation because
of a positive covid test i know these
truckers would love to get face-to-face
with justin trudeau
just to just to plead with with him on
their plight
never going to happen though i mean what
is your take on all this and what
happens when this is all said and done
well my take on all of this is that if
you have pushed canadians of all people
if you've pushed canadians to have to
occupy the capital if you've pushed you
know 50 000 plus truckers and millions
of their supporters to go out in ottawa
when it's negative 20 out to protest for
freedom and just so that they can go to
work and go to school and all of those
things then you've really done something
wrong justin trudeau but trudeau who
much like eric garcetti and gavin newsom
he is clinically incapable of saying
something true
so what did he do he tweeted out
yesterday that this was a group of
islamophobes and anti-semites and
homophobes and there were a couple other
phobes in there and the truth is that
justin trudeau is a freedom of phobe he
is afraid of people living their lives
as they see fit i i hope this is the
beginning of the end of the trudeau
administration canada has said enough is
enough and by the way it's working
they're doing this peacefully and it's
working uh the premier of alberta the
alberta province he now is saying we're
going to scale back on some of this
stuff so it's only because the
individuals the people the truckers
their supporters took their lives into
their own hands that the government is
finally going oh forgot we worked for
you
right
and i will confirm this we had christy
clark on we're going to have her on
again she is a native canadian and she
was our source i don't want to
generalize
and say all canadians are one thing or
not but she says canadians in general
typically tend to roll over and do what
the government tells them and this is
the exception to that rule and it's
great to see them standing up
you know the other thing too you talked
about how justin trudeau has cast this
as a hateful protest
i mean come on nobody's buying that
nobody is buying that and eventually
justin trudeau is going to have to own
up to it
well look i mean we've been showing
videos on my show i'm sure you guys are
showing some of them as well where the
protesters are not only protesting
peacefully they're dancing to bob marley
music they're cleaning up after
themselves they're shoveling snow uh
they're
passing out food to each other it's the
reverse of what we've been shown in the
western world protests are like over the
last two years where we had antifa and
blm burning down cities screaming racist
stuff attacking police officers and the
litany of things that we've all seen for
two years this is a western protest done
right look at those people and justin
trudeau dares he has the gall to look at
those people and say they're out there
because they're irrationally afraid of
trans people that's really what he is
saying i mean i'm not making it up find
the pleasure yourself they have an
irrational fear of trans people that's
why they're out there yeah okay buddy
it's a fringe element according to
justin trudeau so they're shutting the
whole thing down i love that people are
saying you know just two weeks to
flatten the curve here with this protest
to shut down in ottawa just two weeks
that's all they're asking for it might
just be two weeks to flatten justin
trudeau we'll find out
we hope not we you mean rhetorically
speaking of course rhetorically
yes
a metaphor
not i don't want him to be crushed in
some sort of machine that's purely a
metaphor for his career which should be
coming to an end the people have had
enough it's a perfect metaphor dave i
love it i just wanted to be clear you
know thank you don't get shut down dave
rubin great to see you
good to see you if you're looking for
more honest and thoughtful conversations
about politics instead of non-stop
yelling check out our politics playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics watch our full
episode playlist all right over here and
to get notified of all future videos be
sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell